they are sassy they're classy and
honestly probably sometimes gassy it
does like to keep em exactly change
they're the tiniest Royals and basically
our all-time favorites here's a look at
the moments George Charlotte and even
baby Louie stole our hearts George won
our heart the moment we met he's a
little bit of a Roscoe what better that
way
the future king born on July 22nd 2013
with all personalities the other reminds
me of my brother told me when I was
younger I'm not sure George stole the
spotlight at the 2015 trooping the
colour ceremony
charming the world from a window in
Buckingham Palace and very fringe or in
Prince William songs and later with his
balcony debut where the then 22 month
olds
pointed to the crowd below and waved
along with his great gam-gam the Queen
since George has arrived at the Lindo
wing a gesture he displayed one month
earlier when arriving at the hospital to
meet little sister Princess Charlotte
and again when she made her first public
appearance in 2016 of course Charlotte
mastered the Royal wave in no time
that's the princess arriving in Canada
for her first royal tour a trip that
gave us all kinds of adorable moment
including the garden party held for
military families where the kiddos
melted our hearts blowing bubbles
and chasing balloon but when it came to
meeting Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
George was unamused he refused to
high-five and a handshake too it seems
the Obamas are the princes preferred
leaders unless that rocking horse gift
was really just a bribe in 2017 George
and Charlotte hit the road again this
time to Germany and Poland where they
proved they're just like any common
toddler tantrums and all luckily this
helicopters seemed to snap George right
out of his mood
[Music]
[Applause]
the dynamic duo also served as a flower
girl and pageboy in aunty Peppa's
wedding and did they look cute
they wowed the crowd again at Uncle
Harry and Meagan Marcos big day earlier
this year and of course they walked the
aisle at princess Eugenie's October
nuptials where George proved to be one
of the day's biggest stars Allah giving
it is wave waving to the cameras but who
can forget Charlotte adorably hamming it
up on her way to meet new brother Louie
another highlight of 2018 for sure as
was this first pick of the princess with
her younger sibling who is basically the
cutest
[Music]